will you next New Year's Eve be drinking
with Andy Cohn the big decision was made
by Chris Licht who is no longer at CNN
that you and Andy could not take a drink
Andy swears watching Anderson Cooper
take shots is the reason people might
tune in because it's funny to see
straight lace Anderson Cooper takes
shots I also don't drink so yes it's
it's uh but they want you to take shots
uh Andy thinks he's he thinks he's a
programming genius and this is the
secret to success this was a mistake
what will happen this New Year's Eve
will you be on will you be on with with
uh Andy Andy and I will be doing New
Year's Eve together yes and you don't
know if you'll be drinking I have not
had any of those discussions yeah nobody
said anything to me did you think this
was a mistake that you could not drink
on TV look I think uh I think the whole
thing was poorly handled like if
somebody had just come to me and said
look I don't think it's a good idea to
do this
that would have been fine with me I've
been looking fine okay not a big deal
um but it became sort of a public thing
it was said publicly
you know and then it went back and forth
I just thought like it became a thing
that it didn't need to become but look I
thought we had a
a show which was you know which was just
as good uh and you know we came up with
ways to get around it and it became a
thing on the show you know we have Kevin
Hart on the show and he went off uh on
CNN for making this decision uh but it
was a great segment I mean it was a
hilarious segment with Kevin Hart he's a
genius
um so I look I don't know we'll see what
happens to go on with Andy who's you
know and he's an Entertainer and Goofy I
would have thought the first year you
would have been like oh what am I
doing I'm on 60 Minutes I can't be
around with Andy Cohen I don't
think I don't think that way you know
what I I I believe you should just be
yourself I believe that
the a journalist has to be honest in all
things and so part of that is being
honest in who you are and look Walter
Cronkite loved to go sailing maybe if
Walter Cronkite was on television today
he would also have a sailing show on the
Discovery Channel who knows like I think
people audiences are so smart today and
are so aware and know everything about
people it's not like in the days where
you didn't know anything about Walter
cronkite's life who was married to
anything about him and so
I think people know you can be
interested in in you know world events
and care about world events and go to
war zones and you can also like to go to
the movies and see whatever movies you
like to watch or whatever you like to
stream or whatever your other interests
are and so I'm confident enough in
myself that I can make fun of myself and
point out my you know I have a
ridiculous laugh that sounds like a
chicken being strangled and
um you know I that's it I I'm not going
to pretend to be otherwise
foreign